for
[Applause]
thank you very much dear first lady dear
orena ladies and gentlemen what a
pleasure to be here today with you
indeed Ukraine is still going through
very dark times more than 600 days since
since the start of this brutal war that
Russia Unleashed against Ukraine but
today it is about hope today is about
the future today is about the
children and indeed I remember very well
a year ago when we met in Strasburg dear
olena you asked me to help in this
specific topic to alleviate the plight
of Ukrainian children whose schools had
been destroyed by Russian
s and with their schools of course their
world
crumbled and I knew indeed that the
European Union had to do something about
it and to help those children to go to
other
schools so that they could continue
learning and playing and they could
continue being children even in these
difficult times so we had discussed that
why not call on the solidarity of Our
member states
and our regions and cities and
companies and it was overwhelming the
response I was certain that they would
respond but it was amazing to see how
fast and how jubilant they were to
respond immediately and a year on now
we're here the school buses for Ukraine
campaign is a big
success local authorities and companies
from everywhere in our Union donated 200
71 buses and we as you seen in the
little video the European commission
took care of bringing them to Ukraine
and we bought another 100 school buses
so all together today we are at
371 school buses to take the children of
Ukraine to school
safely the Russian war may have robbed
their
childhood and the innocence of their
childhood but it it will not deprive the
children of a bright and happy future
that they deserve I thank everyone each
and everyone here in the room who
contributed to this success the future
should start here today with all of you
and I thank you very much for your
contribution this is a very special day
thank you thank you very much for your
words for your help thank you
[Applause]
d
for
[Applause]
yes
okay
[Applause]
for
speee
spee we
see
psych
problem for those
come we trying to get as close as
possible to the local govern the first
few kills in this car
[Applause]
I
of
support